I'm your host Daniel Dwyer delighted to
be joined as ever by my partner in crime
Chris waters and today we are super
happy to be joined by not only senior
escape goat correspondent Maxwell McGee
yeah it would be me what the creator of
escape coat and escape go to and mr. Ian
stalker thank you very much for taking
the time to join us with that I my
pleasure how are you sir I'm doing great
way to release a game a week after GDC I
bet you've had plenty of sleep this past
week yeah last night i got eight hours
of sleep it just is amazing i imagine is
like a first for you in like the last
year two weeks maybe a month probably
been was just pushed to internet and
then my work here is done in dobie some
ways is just starting yeah but virtual
email inbox is different now than it was
yesterday Maxwell Mickey you're going to
be playing a scapegoat to for us let's
jump right on in here I see your goat
editor I feel it is my sacred duty yes
you show off a little bit of a scapegoat
you showed a scapegoat off on gamespot
for the first time on it came from xbox
live yeah joy studio called it came from
xbox live where we highlighted weird and
quirky xbox live indie games and
actually the original scapegoat along
with the hilarious and terrible no Luca
no worthy to sort of were the impetus as
it were for that show no Luca no of
course being a game where you push a cat
away from bowl cereal guess what God's
name is Luca okay its toll have rather
stay cool for those aquino coming at it
that way yeah i didn't realize the
scapegoat was one of the ones that
launched xsplit was too well no look a
note was sort of the joe game that we
thought oh we should totally ridicule
this game in public because Oh wouldn't
that be funny a scapegoat was the this
is actually really good and it's on xbox
live indie so that means nobody can find
it because these services buried within
like 16 different yes so Ian you've been
developing games you've been working on
games in terms of audio and other stuff
and you develop this is will be your is
it your fourth yeah independent game
you've worked you've made of yourself
for a while their xbox live in these
look like it was a place for students to
just put up kind of just random projects
they worked on I certainly had a bunch
of bands who did that and what was it
why did you put a scapegoat up there and
then were you surprised by the sort of
the reaction
but that came from it so scapegoat was
never chartered to be like a commercial
success I ever designed there was no
design document there's no business plan
it wasn't even designed to be a goat
game from start so it wasn't like I set
out to like how do I make money with
this with go with games so bringing it
to exploit was just like well it's made
in XNA it runs right it's super easy to
get a game up there and you know I I had
done two games already for exploits so
just yeah why not due third one I did it
so I say who was the original hero then
for a scapegoat if it was not the purple
goat we have all come to know not I
placeholder sprites oh no I hate that
character is the word he's in everything
isn't everything was for a while there I
figured that you were some developers
sitting at home when I first saw escape
goat one and you had some sort of maybe
alcohol-induced fever dream where you
came up with the title and then had the
backwards program a video game just so
you could have that IC title of the game
that's a way better story yeah sure
coconut and so far as so for fans of the
scapegoat or for those who have never
played the game ever before you just
kind of explain what it is okay well I
mean watching it is way better than any
sort of explanation because yeah
basically it's a puzzle platformer you
play as a goat and you have to escape
each room dr. Maxwell has just obtained
the signature I don't know gimmick of
the game which is your magical mouse
friend he's this immortal familiar kind
of thing I can get to places you can't
get to in the room by crawling up walls
and ceilings because yeah like 380
little places like yeah right here I
can't my goat is much too big to fit
within this this tiny I hate wouldn't
happen but if I can use my little mouse
friend he can go in there and hit the
button for me so it's a game of teamwork
and totally abandoning your mouse friend
on the other side very my keys book what
look he's figuring it out he's champion
nobody's taking this time I just
launched on steam for pc mac and linux
just yesterday's all right yeah i also
believe the tim schafer was a am pretty
instrumental in developing this game I
believe this is tim schafer's the
scapegoat yeah
you written correctly you guys put out a
pretty good trailer without the guys to
double fine yeah and they've gone and
published this game for you and
something that kind of happened pretty
last minute that would be the very last
minute yeah I mean it was during GDC so
last week yeah last week and you know my
original plan was not to talk to anyone
about publishing until after the pc game
was totally out there yes because i
don't know i just wanted to kind of self
publish on pc and then as i bring this
to consoles maybe talk to publishers but
if double fine expresses interest in
publishing your game maybe rethink your
yeah original plans that they contact
you or was it a happening drunken
meeting at a party at GDC or something
those this came about I don't remember
how much alcohol was involved okay
regional meeting but no we some other
Indies and I loaned space from double
flying down the hall from of course yeah
I get jam and so we kind of just were is
through proximity that they you know saw
the games we were working on and this
was you know pretty much in its final
stages during that month and one of the
things that jumps there for me is that
this game looks noticeably more
attractive than the first game yeah this
is the first game you've collaborated
with someone else on it is so Randy
O'Connor did one hundred percent of the
art backgrounds animations color designs
everything like that and we also have a
custom lighting engine which was written
by Caitlin guide for this game and it's
been open sourced actually which all
accrual cool so if anyone is inspired by
the lighting in this and wants to use it
it's out there ok just was that the
graphics dude for some Tiger style games
so yeah Randy did art for waking mars
and the fantastic looking game when its
owner I yeah I we just happened to be
office maids at the time and I pretty
much just turned 90 degrees from my
office chair and said bye gran D do you
want to thank smart for a sequel to
escape good and I think we just kind of
agreed to do that on the spot making
indie games is so simple you just turn
your chair round someone publishes your
game makes all yours like you don't
forget to shave / depart
shibori about a man bottom move you just
add the goat in the last minute it's
like simple max you you are you have
played the hell a bunch of escape goat
over the past couple years believe I
played one metric Hellebuyck escape
measuring it out in hella unit and what
do you think is the big sort of
difference between this and the first
game oh goodness I mean obviously the
thing that's going to jump out
immediately to everybody is just what
you were talking about with all the
different the upgrades to the visual
fidelity and i think is we're about to
see here some more clever uses of the
fireball spitting grim reaper enemy who
Oh at the app there he goes killed me
plenty of times in the previous game
that's pretty nasty they are nasty but
they're also a utility ok very much
everything in the game is both a hazard
and a utility depending on where it
that's something I just playing through
these initial stages here is yeah
getting like extra mileage as it were
out of your enemies and not just having
them be obstacles or hazards but also
having them work into solving the puzzle
it is very interesting and efficient
design yeah and that's kind of an
interesting sort of way to compound your
puzzle but does it make it does it make
a little more complicated that you like
aren't just bringing in these sort of
one-off things but you want each element
to have multiple applications and
multiple uses I think it actually made
it simpler to make puzzles where every
ingredient has like two or more things
it can do so I could just say like you
know this puzzle is going to feature I
know one reaper and the wood you know
the as you can see the fire propagates
two adjacent wood blocks which I don't
believe it did and yeah that's a brand
new thing and that's everyone's favorite
animation is fire for propagation pretty
great and i can i can i get the keens
you can do it back I better get back I
got a good look at that thing in a bit
of time there we go questions from the
games boss shot here X I to wicked asks
will escape goes to be released on xbox
one I hope so I'd love to bring this
next-gen DHR hoping to I get ya surely
with with Double Fine involved and
you're essentially already publishing it
on steam by on your own right that you
know they got to pull their weight here
and get it on some other platforms all
platforms would you like to see us get
go to work
and the consoles like I mean all three
of the next gen consoles would be
magnificent I think it is a you know a
great console game yeah works great on
PC as well but you know being on the
couch with the controller is my personal
you know preferred way to play it and I
know if Todd McShay we were here he
would say as well that a Vita version
would be pretty great in fact he is here
hi Tom I know you say if only Tom could
somehow send us a message if you will
actually add this perhaps like waving to
us from Baxter this game looks it looks
like something right for for mobile as
well for handheld yeah the Vita thing is
I was actually surprised to see the
number of people that was the number one
requested port yesterday at least on
Twitter when the game got a lot of
attention for launch who's Vita so I
guess we should start thinking about
Vita all right me thank you how did I
think I've gotta get ink max I remember
they mean we're a goat okay uh I've got
to get the guy to shoot the thing at the
thing okk oh I want ask you a question
why do you think about the fact that
goats and never almost become their own
mini genre like you were at their
blazing the trail that's true you know
are involved in goat tech before before
was good holler when people talk about
the history of the goatee onra they
won't be talking about you know the goat
simulator of ladieswear 22,000 28 at the
world at they'll be talking a bit about
how you you started off what do you
think about goat simulator and the how
you birth this new genre with in video
games and why wait I wish yeah I wish
they'd die it's all your fault way to
credit me for you know come up with good
simulator but I think that was an
entirely you know his own thing i don't
know i'm excited i think like a couple
more goat games and we could get her in
tab on steam don't start doing bundles
yeah i'm humble bundle yes it's like
coke on like take that packs got gokon
across the river I like it to be
continued folks and it all started here
on the lobby and we're gonna wrap it up
right there yeah thank you so much for
coming and my shake your hand but I'm
pretty sick so let's go for air five BAM
you